this program is brought to you by Emory
University
fragile X syndrome is a genetic disorder
that leads to a learning disability and
intellectual disability in children and
adults that have it and long with
behavioral disturbances as well it was
first published in 1940s but not
appreciated as very common until the
late 60s and 70s and it became apparent
that it was one of the major inherited
causes of intellectual disability I got
interested in it in early eighties
because of a number of unusual aspects
of fragile x syndrome one was there was
a fragile site on the chromosome on the
X chromosome in patients with the
disorder and that had not been explained
in a molecular level it also give us a
location of the putative gene because we
could actually see it under the
microscope which back then was quite
unusual the other interesting things
about fragile x syndrome were that the
inheritance patterns were very unusual
largely through the work of Stephanie
Sherman here at Emory showing that there
are males that can carry the mutation
but they themselves are unaffected and
at the risk of having an affected child
actually increases as the gene passes
through subsequent generations so there
was a lot of interest in early 80s it
trying to identify the gene responsible
because the thought was it could
illuminate a lot of genetic mechanisms
that we didn't appreciate we started
working on it was very early days before
actually the genome project was started
and the technologies available for
recombinant DNA of the human genome were
very limited and so the technology
technical challenges were quite great in
terms of even equipment we built a lot
of our own equipment in those days
so even though today we have the
sequence of the human genome and it is
proven to be challenging to now
understand complex disease back then
without the tools that we now have
actually understanding when the alien
disorders which today we think of as
very simple to solve was equally as
difficult a major issue with trying to
clone the gene responsible for fragile x
syndrome and the 80s was the location of
the gene itself we didn't have any maps
to speak of that were any high enough
resolution that we could use that to
zero in on the gene we so we devised a
strategy where we introduce the fragile
x chromosome from a patient into a
rodent cell line and we took advantage
of some tricks you can do with cells in
culture in terms of selection to be able
to take advantage of the fragility at
the gene itself where presume where the
gene was and create translocations or
breaks in the human chromosome that
would rejoin at the breakpoint to rodin
chromosomes and by doing so we actually
were able to demarcate where the gene
likely lied net gave us now a means to
look for the breakpoint region in the
hope was that nearby would be a gene and
indeed that was true so when we
identified the gene we discovered there
was a repeat of the DNA in the gene
itself it was a repeat of three
nucleotides cgg normal individuals had
30 copies triplet but surprisingly
patients with fragile X syndrome had
hundreds of copies of the repeat so
dinner when a massive expansion carriers
who themselves were unaffected parents
of parent of a child with fragile X had
an intermediate number of repeats
between 60 and 200 this was quite
surprising because they hadn't been seen
before in any genetically studied
organism
and subsequent to the fragile x syndrome
there's now dozens of disorders now that
are due to try nucleotide repeat
expansions so we knew then that the
mutation was the expansion of the repeat
we use that to develop diagnostic tests
that went very quickly to the clinic and
was vastly superior to any of the tests
that were used before to make the
diagnosis and it allowed families than
to be given more accurate counseling be
able to make more informed decisions
about reproduction and so forth after we
made a diagnostic test the next issue is
really to understand how the repeat
caused the disease so we looked at
expression of the gene and we found that
if the repeat was expanded the gene was
turned off and so it's a lack of this
the protein it was encoded by this gene
that accounted for fragile x syndrome we
now know that the repeat itself triggers
epigenetic change at the locus itself
where the DNA becomes heavily methylated
on the chromatin marks shift to off
state essentially in turn to gene off so
then we knew that the cause of disorder
was the absence of this protein the
problem was this protein or anything
brought any protein like this had never
been seen before so we didn't know what
it really did so we did early steps we
as to where it was in the body where it
was expressed and indeed it's expressed
heavily in the brain we asked where in
the neuron it was expressed and what
cellular components was it associated
with and from a number of labs including
my own we made the discovery that the f
more protein was associated with
ribosomes so it was involved in protein
translation and I was particularly
interesting in that it was involved in
protein translation at the synapse
we're two neurons interact and it was
known from work in other organisms that
to lay down a memory one needs new
protein synthesis to occur at the
location of the synapse and so being
this protein normally was associate of
ribosomes at the synapse it was likely
then it played a role in actually memory
and learning and of course I made sense
given the phenotype of the patients for
many years it wasn't clear there would
be a therapeutic approach short of some
sort of gene therapy in the brain which
didn't seem likely anytime soon so you
know the best way to deal with that
situation to move forward just do basic
science try to understand more and more
about what the impact on a neuron is if
you don't have this protein what this
protein normally does and so forth and
that's what we focused on for many years
and we ended up with a fairly detailed
understanding of what this protein
normally doesn't interneuron and what
the consequence of its absence was in
fragile x syndrome and then it became
apparent that there may be targets where
drugs could be used to counteract the
losses protein so this protein normally
sort of tones down the excitability of a
synapse after it gets fired so if you
don't have the protein this the synapse
appears to be over stimulated in one
receptor in particular the EM glow are
five receptor appears downstream that
it's over stimulated so the notion
became apparent that if one had a drug
than antagonized that receptor one could
maybe bring things more into balance
there were experimental compounds that
would do that they weren't necessarily
effective as a drug but in a laboratory
animal they were sufficient and
of labs very quickly we're able to show
that these drugs in fact reversed all
the phenotypes of fragile x syndrome
both in mice and in fruit fly models of
the disorder so number of large
pharmaceutical companies became
interested in trying to develop similar
antagonists that had characteristics
that would make them a better drug in
humans and while they were doing that we
embarked also on a drug screen to try to
identify other compounds that might
similarly rescue phenotypes and we used
the drosophila model of fragile x
syndrome in order to screen compounds
mostly known drugs that might reverse
the phenotype in the flies and in fact
we identified the GABA agonist as
another class of compound that could
reverse the consequence of the loss of
frp the advantage of that is there
already drugs approved that were GABA
agonist so today now there are clinical
trials with both kinds of drugs now the
implore 5 antagonists that a number of
pharmaceutical companies have come up
with compounds as well as the GABA
agonist currently are about five drug
trials going on here at Emory as well as
cross country and a couple more slated
to begin this summer yeah I would say
that you know the one of the first
things we did when we started the
Department of Human Genetics was
established a fragile x syndrome clinic
so these patients would have a medical
home and it's proven to be very
beneficial to the family very useful for
our research and then when it came about
that there might be drugs entering
clinical trial phases we already had the
infrastructure setup in order to
participate in the clinical trials and
jeanne was soo Teck one of the faculty
members in the department runs a clinic
and also has a master's degree in
clinical research so it worked out quite
well people that do medical research
hope I think at some point their work
might lead to
improvements in the lives of patients of
the disease a study but I think very few
scientists actually achieve that goal
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University